* Herzschläge *
Ich wollte weder einen so viel
Jüngeren noch einen Kanadier.
Aber es soll eben so sein.
Ich war, um es so zu sagen,
hin und weg,
als ich sie via Skype
auf dem Bildschirm sah.
Zu Beginn wollte ich immer
das letzte Wort haben.
Credo che la tengo io.
Sie sagt sie, ich sage ich.
- Si, la tengo io.
Tu la tieni? Io la tengo.
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
Machen wir Hula-Hoop.
- Hula-Hoop. Mama Hula-Hula-Hoop.
Als ich darauf wartete, dass Lana
in die Schweiz kommen würde,
hat mich jemand anonym angerufen
und ungefähr gesagt:
"Hey, Krättli,
du kannst nach Chur hinunter gehen
an die Rossbodenstrasse,
deine Stute ist angekommen."
An der Rossbodenstrasse
halten sich abends
die Prostituierten auf.
Es war also quasi
ein Hinweis in diese Richtung.
Einen solchen anonymen Anruf
habe ich erhalten.
No, it's too fast for you.
(Bei Sprüchen unter die Gürtellinie
nicht hinhören -
das haben Krättlis gelernt.)
(Sie kämpfen für ihre Liebe
und manchmal
auch gegen überflüssige Kilos.)
Cool!
Also 13 Min. für 100 Kalorien.
Ui, ui, ui.
Ich muss unbedingt abnehmen.
Für Miami Beach muss ich wieder
schlank und hübsch werden, oder?
Ja, ja.
Wenn ich den Vergleich ziehe:
Ich bin momentan
ziemlich genau 10 kg schwerer
als zum Zeitpunkt unserer Hochzeit.
Unterdessen bin ich immerhin
unter 100 kg, noch 98 kg.
Aber das Ziel wäre schon, in Zukunft
wieder unter 90 zu kommen.
Aber das ist natürlich schwierig,
weil sie so gut kocht
und ich gerne Süsses mag.
* Verspielte Klänge *
I almost lost 150 calories. 136.
Hier ist die Wohnung. Das ist der
Ausblick nach draussen übers Wasser.
Wow! Wie heisst dieses Wasser?
Was ist das? Lake ...
Das ist eigentlich ein Kanal.
- Ein Kanal? - Ja.
Werden wir Geräte haben?
- Geräte?
Ja, da ist alles ... Everything
here. Dishes and everything.
Super.
- Ja, Mikrowelle, Backofen, alles.
Das ist besser als das,
was wir haben. - Neuer.
Wow, super, super, super!
Es war immer mein Traum,
nach Amerika zu fliegen.
Wir hatten Martins Bildungsurlaub
schon vor 1 1/2 Jahren geplant,
oder?
Oder war es vor zwei Jahren?
Oh, verzeihe!
Ich lebe schon so lange mit Martin,
dass ich glaube, er könne Russisch.
Als ob wir schon 50 und nicht erst
sechs Jahre zusammen wären.
Ich freue mich sehr,
im Frühling nach Miami zu reisen.
Ich bin stolz auf meinen Mann,
dass er uns als Familie diese Reise
an diesen schönen Ort ermöglicht.
Then we go to Key West
one weekend ...
(Nach 22 Jahren
an der Schule in Thusis
kann Martin
einen Bildungsurlaub beziehen.)
(Sechs Wochen Sprachaufenthalt
in den USA -
alles ist gebucht, es fehlt
nur noch das Visum für Lana.)
(Aber auch das haben sie beantragt.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge
und Herzschläge *
Der ÖV in der Schweiz
ist einfach sensationell.
Wenn du hier den Bus nehmen willst,
musst du erst 20 Min. zu Fuss gehen.
Dann musst du schauen,
ob der Bus überhaupt fährt.
Man hat zwei Städte
wie Winterthur und Zürich,
und am Samstag
fährt während 4 Std. kein Bus.
Dann muss man herausfinden,
wann der Bus fährt.
Am besten mit Google,
weil sie keine gute Homepage haben.
Das Geld muss man passend mitnehmen,
weil es keinen Billettautomaten hat.
Sie machen es einem nicht einfach.
- Vive le Quebec!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Thomas sagte schon,
es habe noch viel Schnee im März.
Aber ich habe es mir doch
etwas weniger imposant vorgestellt.
Das ist ja krass.
(Kanada schläft noch,
als ich frühmorgens durch das Wohn-
quartier am Stadtrand Quebecs fahre.)
* Vogelkrächzen *
Ach, schau mal an!
Hallo, wer bist denn du, du Schöne?
* Schrille Türklingel *
Ich glaube, es ist schon jemand wach.
Hallo Thomas!
- Ja, hallo!
(Es sind ein paar Monate vergangen,
seit Thomas Kleiber bei mir im Radio
seine letzte Wetterprognose
gemacht hat.)
(Jetzt lebt er bei seinem Mann David
und bei seinen Schwiegereltern.)
Trois?
- Trois!
(In Quebec, wo auch im März
noch tiefer Winter herrscht.)
Und all das macht Thomas
aus Liebe zu dir?
Ja, genau.
Für dich schaufle ich sogar Schnee.
Seid ihr schon eingerichtet?
- Ja, etwas haben wir verändert.
(Hier im Untergeschoss ist also
Thomas Kleibers neues Zuhause.)
Das haben wir neu gemacht,
vorher hatte es andere Farben.
Wir haben es heller gestrichen,
weil das Tiefparterre
nicht so hell ist.
Ja, sind das eure einzigen Fenster -
dann noch mit so viel Schnee davor?
Ja, deshalb habe ich ein Loch
geschaufelt. Sonst wäre es schwarz.
Dieses Loch ist nicht natürlich.
Eigentlich hätte es hier 1 m Schnee.
Es schaut jetzt wirklich viel besser
aus hier, mehr nach unserem Stil.
Es ist jetzt unser Zimmer.
"Francais!"
Genau, das haben David und ich
in der Schweiz gemacht.
Das hattet ihr bereits.
- Genau, in der Schweiz.
Die Idee war, immer abzuwechseln.
- Maintenant c'est en Francais.
Die Grundlage jeder Integration
ist die Sprache,
wie du dein Umfeld schaffst,
deinen Humor.
Wie du dich eingibst, wie du Kontakt
zu den Leuten aufnimmst.
(Thomas Kleiber)
Ich finde oft die Worte nicht.
Ich kann nicht
mit der Sprache spielen.
Et ca, tu fais beaucoup.
Du spielst so oft mit der Sprache.
Wenn wir mit Leuten unterwegs sind
wie gestern Abend,
fühle ich mich
wie der Langweiler vom Dienst.
Bis ich in der schnellen Diskussion
einen Satz zustande bringe,
ist das Sujet schon wieder vorbei.
Wenn man einen ironischen Spruch
bringen möchte,
muss man sprachlich präzise sein.
Das kann ich nicht,
mein Humor kommt nicht an.
Sie sind eine lustige Familie,
sie lachen oft.
Ich kann einfach
nichts dazu beitragen.
Ich fühle mich ziemlich langweilig.
Das ist frustrierend.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Noch etwas frustriere ihn
jetzt im Winter.)
(Diese Schneemenge kommt dem passio-
nierten Radfahrer Thomas ungelegen.)
(Ohne eigenes Auto
ist er immer auf andere angewiesen,
um von A nach B zu kommen.)
(So ist der Ex-"Meteo"-Mann derzeit
Schneeschaufler im Hauptfach.)
Hallo, hilfst du uns?
Da sind wir aber dankbar.
Du hilfst uns beim Schaufeln?
- Wir sind schon fast fertig.
Dumm ist, dass es weiterhin schneit.
Hinter dem Haus
mache ich dann weiter, siehst du.
Wir stehen hier auf 3,5 m Schnee.
- Unfassbar. Bis das alles schmilzt.
Du kannst hinunterrutschen,
wenn du möchtest.
Hinunter schlitteln!
- Dort hat es Eis, aber hier geht's.
Warte,
sonst stürze ich noch in den Tod.
Achtung, fertig ...
* Lachen *
Nicht schlecht, oder?
- Das ist super.
Was man halt so macht in Quebec.
Komm!
- Hey bravo!
* Lachen *
Sie lernten Brigitte kennen
und waren alle happy.
V.a. mein Vater
als Stammesoberhaupt.
Er war so angetan und dankte ihr,
dass sie mir wieder auf die Beine
geholfen hat.
Was sagte er noch mal?
Er sagte: "Wenn er dich jemals
schlagen sollte, sagst du mir es!"
Als ob ich Frauen schlagen würde.
So etwas würde ich nie tun.
Aber er sagte das. Danke, Dad.
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
(Es ist eiskalt in Montana.)
(Brigitte und Jay
sind auf dem Weg zum Powwow,
dem traditionellen Stammesfest
mit Tanz und Musik.)
I'm so excited for the Powwow!
(Jay erinnert sich noch einmal daran,
wie er Brigitte
seiner Familie vorgestellt hat.)
Ich brachte sie ins Haus
meiner Eltern.
Mein Vater
schien sie sofort zu mögen.
Er hatte ein breites Lachen
und sagte: "Woher kommst du?"
Sie sagte: "Aus der Schweiz."
Und er sagte: "Toll."
Er erzählte, dass er als junger Mann
beinahe eine Schweizerin
geheiratet hätte,
als er in Europa
Militärdienst leistete.
Und alles war sofort wunderbar.
* Mystische Flötenklänge *
* Vogelzwitschern *
(Auf dem Weg zum Powwow
kommen Jay und Brigitte
an einem heiligen Ort vorbei.)
* Gläsernes Klirren *
* Rauschender Wind *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Meine Heimat ist schon die Schweiz.
Es fühlt sich zwar vertraut an,
weil ich schon oft hier war
und es langsam kenne.
Aber ich werde hier nie
ein Gefühl von Zuhause haben
wie in der Schweiz,
wo ich geboren und aufgewachsen bin.
Okay, good.
(Auch deshalb haben sie beschlossen,
bald ihre Zelte in den USA
abzubrechen
und in die Schweiz zu ziehen.)
Wir hatten uns entschieden,
in die Schweiz zu ziehen,
bevor Trump gewählt wurde.
Doch nun
mussten wir darüber nachdenken,
was die Veränderungen
für uns bedeuten würden.
Denn es waren
keine guten Veränderungen.
Wir haben v.a. festgestellt,
dass Rassismus wieder aufkommt.
Viele Leute haben das Gefühl,
das sei erlaubt.
Der Präsident geht mit
seinen Äusserungen und Tweets etc.
als Beispiel voran.
Das widerspricht
den indianischen Prinzipien:
Wir sind für Mutter Erde
und für das Leben eines jeden.
Und das versucht er zu zerstören.
Er ist gegen alles,
woran ich glaube.
* Mystische Flötenklänge *
* Indianische Gesänge und Trommeln *
Wir waren
noch nicht einmal verheiratet,
da wollte er bereits
ein Papier unterschreiben
für den Fall einer Scheidung.
Ich wollte eine Gütertrennung
unterschreiben lassen, weil ich sah,
wie lange der Scheidungsprozess
meiner Eltern dauerte.
Ich hatte gar nicht viel -
ein Schweizer Bankkonto,
auf dem ich meinen Lehrlingslohn
angespart hatte.
Und sie fragte:
"Du willst dich bereits scheiden
lassen, bevor wir heiraten?"
"Steig auf dein Fahrrad
und fahr weiter!"
So wurde keine Gütertrennung unter-
schrieben und ich bin auch froh.
Das ist ...
das Ebenbild meiner Vergangenheit.
Ich bin froh, dass ich
nicht mehr so bin wie früher -
dank ihr und ihrer Familie.
* Schnelle Xylophonklänge
und Sirenen *
* Schnelle spanische Gitarre *
(Vor achteinhalb Jahren prallten zwei
verschiedene Welten aufeinander.)
(Gepasst hat es trotzdem.)
(Der Schweizer UBS-Bänker
auf Weltreise
und die Psychologiestudentin
aus Mexiko.)
(Nancy sagt lustigerweise,
sie habe es kommen sehen.)
(Sie habe ihrem Onkel
vor vielen Jahren prophezeit,
dass sie einmal
Einen von weit weg finden werde.)
Ich sagte: "Weisst du was?"
"Ich werde einen heiraten,
der mit mir die Welt bereist."
"Make me travel the world."
- Make me travel the world!
Und der mit mir verrückte Dinge tut.
Ich war noch ein Kind,
als ich das sagte.
Und eines Tages,
als ich mich mit Demis aufmachte,
erinnerte mich mein Onkel daran,
dass nun alles wahr geworden sei.
"You remember that day?
It's true, it happens now."
* Mexikanische Gitarren-
und Trompetenmusik *
* Nancy summt
eine mexikanische Melodie. *
* Traditionelle Mariachi-Musik *
Ich hatte zuvor nie eine Freundin,
weil ich mich nie verliebt habe.
Ich wusste nie, was Liebe ist.
Ich hatte immer Lust zu reisen
und einen Drang, die Welt zu sehen.
Das konnte ich nur
mit einer Weltreise befriedigen.
Ich konnte diesen Durst nie löschen,
bis ich Nancy kennenlernte,
die eher sesshaft war und mich durch
jegliche Abenteuer begleiten wollte.
Obwohl sie zuvor noch nie
aus Mexiko herausgekommen war,
begleitete sie mich auf der
Fahrradreise von Alaska nach Mexiko.
Sie konnte zuvor
nicht Fahrradfahren.
Ich wusste: Diese Frau wird mit mir
durch dick und dünn gehen.
* Sanfte romantische Klänge *
* Sie sprechen Spanisch. *
Was ich an David am meisten schätze:
Ich habe noch nie einer Person
so sehr vertraut.
Er ist ein so
unglaublich schlechter Lügner,
dass er gezwungen ist,
immer die Wahrheit zu sagen.
Ich kann ihn so einfach lesen. Ich
merke, wenn ihn etwas beschäftigt.
Es ist schön, jemanden zu haben, der
das Gefühl und das Vertrauen hat.
Was v.a. schön ist: Ich habe meine
Schwächen und er kenn mich gut.
Man wird es kaum glauben,
aber ich habe Schwächen.
Diese Schwächen akzeptiert er,
er wirft sie mir nicht vor.
Für mich ist er vom Gefühl her
einer der reinsten Menschen,
die ich kenne.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Trillerpfeife *
(Nebst dem langen Winter gibt es
in Quebec eine weitere Spezialität:
Poutine - Pommes frites und Gummi-
käsewürfel mit viel Bratensauce.)
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Für Foodporn im Internet
eignet sich Poutine nicht wirklich.
Nein, daraus machst du
keine Insta-Storys.
Es ist leider fein.
Wir können David sagen, ich sei
schon fast integriert. - Ja, fast.
(David arbeitet unterdessen
im Cafe seiner Familie in der Küche.)
(Dass Thomas noch keinen Job hat,
sieht er entspannt.)
Voila.
Wenn er jetzt noch nicht arbeiten
will, verstehe ich das.
Er wird bestimmt eines Tages etwas
finden, das er wirklich gerne macht.
Wir müssen das beide
ganz entspannt nehmen.
Ich bin glücklich,
dass ich ihn unterstützen kann.
Es ist eine schöne Gelegenheit,
ihm davon etwas zurückzugeben,
was er mir gegeben hat.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
* Trillerpfeife *
Oh, was wird hier gemacht?
- Das Dach wird geräumt.
Wir können auch
von hier aus schauen.
Da ist abgesperrt,
niemand darf vorbeigehen?
Sie werden uns
schon wieder vorbeigehen lassen.
* Trillerpfeife *
So.
- Es ist wie auf dem Fussballplatz.
* Lachen *
Wenn du zu langsam bist,
kommt halt die nächste Ladung.
(Auch wenn Thomas ein Winterfan ist,
sehnt er sich nach dem Frühling.)
* Trillerpfeife *
(Für seine Schwiegermutter Jocelyne
hat er sogar einen programmiert.)
Das habe ich für Jocelyne gemacht.
Ich kann hier -
viel schneller als die anderen -
den Frühling erwecken.
* Lachen *
Na? So muss das sein.
Wie ist das eigentlich -
ich stelle es mir schwierig vor -
in deinem und auch meinem Alter
bei den Schwiegereltern einzuziehen?
Sie machen es mir wirklich
so einfach wie möglich.
Sie lassen mir alle Freiheiten
und haben von Beginn weg gesagt:
"Wenn du deine Ruhe haben möchtest,
zieh dich einfach zurück."
"Wir verlangen nicht,
dass du etwas mit uns unternimmst."
Sie sind sehr lustig und herzlich,
aber ich bin jemand,
der zwar gerne unter Leuten ist,
aber auch gerne seine Ruhe hat.
Private Partnermomente - gemeinsam
nach Hause kommen, etwas kochen,
sich unterhalten - all das
fällt weg, weil immer jemand da ist.
David und ich vermissen
dieses normale Pärchenleben schon,
wie wir es in Zürich hatten.
Deshalb hätten wir gerne
bald wieder eine eigene Wohnung,
um wieder unsere Privatsphäre
zu haben.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
(Aber um Arbeit zu finden, muss er
erst einmal Französisch büffeln.)
(Im Moment noch online.)
* Schnurren *
Mit der temporären
Niederlassungsbewilligung
kann ich mich jetzt für Französisch-
kurse in Klassen bewerben.
Das wäre mir viel lieber.
Online ist zwar okay, aber wenn
Fragen auftauchen, ist es mühsam.
Wenn man eine Übung nicht versteht,
muss man sie trotzdem durchziehen.
Ich muss immer auf David warten,
um ihn dann abends zu fragen.
Und man ist halt einfach allein.
Ich würde gerne Leute kennenlernen.
Klar kann man Dinge planen.
Aber das heisst nicht,
dass es dann auch so funktioniert.
Ich glaube, bei ihr sind Spuren
ihrer Jugend zu erkennen,
aus dem System des Kommunismus,
in dem sie aufgewachsen ist.
Da gab es noch Fünf-
und Siebenjahrespläne,
die durchgezogen wurden, auch wenn
alles chaotisch und scheisse war.
Sie haben am Plan festgehalten,
obwohl sie Schiffbruch erlitten.
Sie hat 20 Jahre in diesem System
gelebt, das ist sicher prägend.
(An diesem Morgen haben Martin und
Lana aber alles minuziös geplant.)
(Sie sind auf dem Weg
zur US-Botschaft in Bern.)
(Für Lana als Ukrainerin ist es
nicht einfach, in die USA zu reisen.)
Was ist das? Ordner files ...
Ich kann das nicht absagen.
Es ist alles gebucht.
Auch meine Stellvertretung
ist organisiert.
Ich kann das
nicht mehr rückgängig machen.
Wenn sie die Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
das Visum nicht bekommt,
muss ich halt allein fahren.
Entschuldige, Martin!
Ja, ja.
- Ich dachte ...
Ich sagte, es seien drei.
Aber es sind drei wichtige
und zwei mit anderen Dokumenten.
Alles perfekt.
Don't worry, be happy.
* Sanfte Mandolinenklänge *
Here's your queue. Okay? So ...
- I will go.
Good! Okay.
* Langgezogene Gitarrenklänge *
So etwas macht mich immer nervös.
Aber ich sehe keinen Grund, weshalb
sie das Visum verweigern sollten.
* Sanfte Westerngitarrenklänge *
Okay. And? Alles okay?
- Yes, yes, everything is okay.
Cool, okay.
- So let's go.
(Hürden überwinden und Neues anpacken
schweisst zusammen.)
(Das nächste Ziel von Martin und Lana
heisst: Miami.)
* Herzschläge *
Ich glaube,
wir ergänzen uns sehr gut.
Sie lernt von mir,
ich lerne von ihr.
Klar,
wir haben diesen kulturellen Gap,
unsere Kommunikation
ist unterschiedlich.
Aber wir versuchen, unsere Kulturen
gegenseitig kennenzulernen.
* Sanfte Slide-Gitarrenklänge *
(Zwischenhalt bei Jays Bruder Darby
und dessen Frau Kathleen.)
It's cold, huh?
Knock knock! Knock knock!
(Die beiden Frauen studieren
schon mal das Festprogramm.)
(Es gibt einen Kuchenesswettbewerb.)
Pie eating contest? Who won?
- I don't know.
I didn't get to go.
- You didn't get to go.
(Die beiden Brüder
sehen sich nicht so oft.)
(Aber Darby spürt, dass Jay mit
Brigitte eine Frau gefunden hat,
die gut zu ihm passt.)
Brigitte ist
eine tolle Persönlichkeit.
Sie ist sehr nett
und passt ins Leben der Indianer.
Sie war in der Familie
sofort akzeptiert.
Sie liebt Gartenarbeit
und kocht sehr gut.
Sie ist naturverbunden.
Und er ist durch sie
etwas ruhiger geworden.
Seine Harley hat er zwar immer noch.
* Sanfte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Jetzt muss ich schauen,
dass ich es durchs Ohr bringe.
(Im Alltag blieb nicht mehr viel von
der früheren indianischen Kultur.)
(Umso liebevoller
pflegen die Stammesmitglieder
die Traditionen, die es noch gibt.)
* Sanfte E-Gitarren-Klänge *
(Das Powwow findet in Fort Belknap
statt, in der Bingohalle.)
(In Fort Belknap leben 7'000 Menschen
mit indianischen Wurzeln
aus zwei verschiedenen Stämmen.)
* Indianische Gesänge und Trommeln *
Ich bin jedes Mal aufgeregt,
bei jedem Powwow.
Nach den ersten paar Tänzen
lässt die Nervosität nach.
Ich weiss nicht weshalb.
Es ist so etwas wie Lampenfieber.
* Indianische Gesänge und Trommeln *
* Rhythmisches Trommeln
und Nachahmen von Vogelkrächzen *
Wenn Brigitte mit mir tanzt,
wird mein Herz leicht.
Es überkommt mich auch eine Wehmut,
denn die Frauen unseres Stammes
tanzen nicht mehr.
Brigitte ist zwar
nicht native american,
aber sie ist meine Seelenverwandte.
Die Leute akzeptieren das.
Das ist das Gute,
wenn du die Frau findest,
mit der du zusammenleben willst.
Sie ist die meine.
Wir glauben,
dass wir vorher zusammen waren
und für immer zusammen sein werden.
In einem nächsten Leben vielleicht
nicht in dieser Form, aber zusammen.
Wir sind einander vertraut.
Wir gehören zusammen.
In unserem Alter haben beide einen
Rucksack mit Lebenserfahrungen -
mit guten und schlechten.
Man bringt eine Prägung mit sich,
daran muss man manchmal arbeiten.
* Rhythmisches Trommeln *
(Weisse Bärin,
die von weither kommt -
so haben die Nakotas
Brigitte getauft.)
(Und vielleicht geht sie bald zurück
in die Schweiz.)
(Diesmal jedoch zusammen mit Jay.)
(Wir wünschen den beiden
nur das Beste.)
Ich glaube, bei Secondos wie mir ...
Mein Vater migrierte aus Spanien
in die Schweiz,
meine Mutter aus Italien,
ich bin in der Schweiz geboren.
Wir sagen immer: "Ich bin Italiener"
oder "Ich bin Spanier."
Aber eigentlich
sind wir alle Schweizer.
Dafür braucht es Gefühl!
- Kennst du einen Trick?
Dreimal hier, zweimal da?
- Mit Gefühl!
(Demis und Nancy
sind zu Besuch in der Schweiz,
bei Demis' Mutter in Birmensdorf.)
(Sie musste sich damit abfinden, dass
sie ihren Sohn nur selten sieht.)
(Bereits vor gut zehn Jahren, als
Demis packte und auf Weltreise ging.)
Die Reise dauerte länger und länger.
Irgendwann habe ich verstanden,
dass er jemanden kennenlernen und
nicht mehr nach Hause kommen wird.
Aber als Mutter ist es hart.
Das möchte man ja nicht.
Man hätte gerne
eine Schwiegertochter, die da ist.
Aber bei einer so tollen Schwieger-
tochter gebe ich ihn gerne her.
So, stellen wird das hier hin.
Mama, ich mache
ein paar Instagram-Storys.
Una, dos, tres!
Das habe ich gehört!
(Ob in der Schweiz
oder zu Hause in Mexiko,
Nancy und Demis teilen alles
mit ihren Fans auf Social Media.)
(Manchmal posten sie
ganz Alltägliches
und manchmal teilen sie mit uns die
wirklich grossen Momente des Lebens.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
No manches!
No manches, amor!
Was ist passiert?
- Schliess die Augen, Mama!
Gib mir deine Hände!
Jetzt darfst du die Augen öffnen.
* Romantische Melodie *
# Take my hand.
* Summen *
(Und so gross ist das Glück.)
(Wir gratulieren Nancy und Demis
und sind jetzt schon gespannt,
wo sie das Leben als Familie
hinführen wird.)
(Nach Mexiko, in die Schweiz
oder an einen ganz anderen Ort.)
(Zu Hause sind diese beiden
so oder so auf der ganzen Welt.)
# Oh take my hand.
Weshalb habt ihr
so früh geheiratet?
* David imitiert
ein schreiendes Kind. *
(Dass man unter 8 Mrd. Menschen
den richtigen für sich findet,
ist per se
bereits ein kleines Wunder.)
(Und wenn der oder die eine
am anderen Ende der Welt wohnt,
braucht es gleich noch einmal
ein Wunder für ein Happy End.)
Das ist riesig.
- Ja, es ist gross.
(Die Frage bleibt wohl
für immer unbeantwortet,
was einen genau dazu bewegt,
alles hinter sich zu lassen
und Ja zu sagen.)
(So wie es Thomas und David
an genau diesem Ort machten.)
Du sagtest, du wollest
nur eine Hochzeit im kleinen Rahmen.
Da siehst du wieder, wer
in unserer Beziehung das Sagen hat.
Ja, genau.
Das ist wirklich
wie in "Vom Winde verweht".
Wie waren die drei Jahre,
in denen ihr zusammengelebt habt?
Man darf es fast nicht sagen:
Wir sind sehr stolz auf uns.
Ich finde, wir haben das beide
extrem gut gemacht.
Auch was danach kam,
die Herausforderung.
Auch unsere Familien und Freunde.
Immer ist einer von uns weggegangen,
es war immer ein Hin und Her.
Wir waren teilweise
monatelang voneinander getrennt.
Ich finde,
wir konnten sehr gut damit umgehen.
Wir sind sehr stolz.
Es gab schöne Augenblicke
aber auch schwierige.
Ich will nicht verheimlichen,
dass es auch
diese schwierige Situationen gab.
Dass wir es geschafft haben,
das macht mich sehr stolz.
Wir passen einfach super zusammen
und ergänzen uns gut.
Er würde dich immer
und immer wieder heiraten.
(Thomas Kleiber)
I would do it again.
(David) Me too, really.
* Lachen*
(Thomas Kleiber) Der Kleine!
* Er ahmt das Ächzen
der Anstrengung nach. *
Cute!
Hallo!
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wow! Das sieht schon ...
- C'est cool, huh?
David, was wünschst du dir
für eure gemeinsame Zukunft?
Ich wünsche mir, dass wir uns
nicht zu viele Sorgen machen.
Dass uns die Zukunft nicht belastet.
Dass wir zusammenbleiben
und dass es uns gut geht,
egal, wo wir leben werden.
Ob wir wieder in die Schweiz
zurückkehren oder hierbleiben,
lassen wir das Leben
und unsere Gefühle entscheiden.
Was wünschst du dir? Was ist für dich
das Wichtigste für die Zukunft?
Ich wünsche mir, dass ich es
schaffe, hier in Quebec Dinge,
Orte und Menschen zu finden,
bei denen ich mich zu Hause fühle.
Dass es mit der Zeit Dinge gibt,
an die ich mich erinnere -
wie auch in der Schweiz -,
an Geschichten, Menschen und Leben.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass ich auch hier ein Zuhause habe
und auch in der Schweiz Sehnsucht
nach Quebec und Kanada hätte.
Schauen wir einmal vorbei?
- (Thomas Kleiber) Ja.
# It takes me, breaks me,
tears me up inside.
# But when you smile,
your beauty shines so bright.
# It moves me, you choose me,
wherever I may lie.
# You say: "Go on and tell me
where you wanna go tonight."
# Break out the sad songs
and take them on your right.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich mich
nicht aufopfern musste.
Wenn du glaubst, dass es Aufopferung
ist, dann ist es keine Liebe.
Liebe gibst du automatisch.
Gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt!
Erstens: niemals aufgeben
und daran glauben,
dass eine Person da draussen ist,
die für einen bestimmt ist.
Man soll nicht angestrengt suchen,
das funktioniert nicht.
Es geschieht,
wenn es geschehen soll.
Ich sage ihr jeden Tag:
"Ich liebe dich." Jeden Morgen.
Ich berühre sie immer wieder.
So bleiben wir verbunden.
Wir beenden sogar
gegenseitig unsere Sätze.
Ich liebe ihn so, wie er ist.
Er ist gutmütig,
grosszügig und intelligent.
Er ist einfach mein Mann.
Es wäre natürlich schon cool, wenn
ich ihre Sprache sprechen könnte.
Es wäre auch eine Wertschätzung
Lana gegenüber gewesen,
wenn ich etwas besser Russisch
gelernt hätte.
Das hätte ich anders machen sollen.
* Meeresrauschen und Möwenschreie *
(Und dann,
als der Film schon fast zu Ende war,
erreichte uns vom anderen Ende der
Welt eine wunderbare Nachricht:
Auch in Neuseeland
gibt es Nachwuchs.)
(Katja und Jay erwarten ein
Geschwister für die kleine Inaria.)
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
# Take my, take my hand.
(Hin und weg - wir lernten
viele Menschen kennen, die zeigen,
dass Liebe Grenzen und Hindernisse
überwinden kann.)
(Die Sendung ist zu Ende, doch
ihre Liebesgeschichten gehen weiter.)
# As long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me, take my hand.